so what is gravity a downward force
yeah something that's so see from flying
away well it keeps me on the earth it's
just I don't I don't fly away it says
this indescribable thing that kind of
keeps us from flying off into space this
is what's keeping me on the ground it's
not gravity gravity is that which keeps
us constantly Kazu on this particular
hello gravity would be the natural
tendency for things to move towards
massive objects like the earth I suppose
it would be the largest mass or the most
powerful mass which is what the Sun so
the Sun affects all the other planets
pulling it around what is gravity
gravity is the force that attracts moon
to the earth it actually attracts
smaller
planets to the bigger ones you're
thinking cuz this is the moon this is
obviously the king it's affecting it
it's pulling it because the earth is
bigger it has a gravitational pull like
the moon has a gravitational pull
towards me there
I know it's applied like it is gathered
depending on the mass of an object
that's probably about all I know about
gravity that and that it's towards the
center of an object's gravity is full of
the core of the earth does gravity exist
anywhere else but to the core of the
earth that's around the Sun yeah yeah so
do you have a gravitational pull I
imagine to be very small but yeah but
what does the moon have its own gravity
yes because it has nets
do you have gravity yes because I'm
awesome
it's bodies with mass they're attracted
to each other
is that true all bodies with mass I
don't know I think so
so are you attracted to that tree I
don't know probably like not very much
but maybe a little bit